[Music]
I guess the first thing I'll ask you is
how did you come about this story that
seems to be uh so indicative of so many
of the Contemporary and historical
problems that exist here in
America well uh if uh you know my other
films uh normally uh I try to stay away
from stories that are too personal and
that are too uh specific but this
particular story was so
extraordinarily uh touching to
everything that we know about this
country about the origin of this country
and about the problems that still exist
today so I was approached by by um uh
propa Amazon and juvie production Violet
Davis company yeah uh and in fact they
wanted me to produce the film and and I
saw the material I I spoke with
everybody uh Li presser article which is
an incredible piece of
Journalism uh and I visit the family as
well and at that point uh I I you know I
saw that what kind of story that could
be and then I decided to direct it as
well yeah uh so we talked backstage and
I said I told you that when I watched
the film I was struck by
how it so uniquely
captures um American
inequity uh the Caro system and the way
these men were put in jail um capitalism
in terms of the way that this family's
land and their legacy and their history
was used as just another tool to enrich
some other country uh some other company
should I say uh so much going wrong for
for the family but the power of the
family is in the fact that they are so
loving and so close what did you learn
about the Real's family while you were
making the film well when I met them I
think that's one of the thing uh that
really uh uh pushed me to to to do the
movie it was the fact that they have
been fighting for decades it's not just
a fight of a few years uh it started way
before you know when Kim one of the
women she was in school when the the the
problem started as she says so um this
incredible Vigor and and resistance
resilience of this family was something
that throughout uh carried not only me
but everybody involved uh in that story
and the Family itself um and there are
incredible characters they they mommy is
funny she's intelligent she is she
understood precisely very complex
economical process because she gives you
you know when she said you know what's
going to happen to us black people and
then she correct herself us poor people
yeah you know that's a class analysis
right there so uh it's it's uh
incredible the the amount of
concentrated stories beyond that family
real story that are in in this in this
film you know like I'm I like to go into
movies like not knowing anything right
except for my Marvel movies and I got to
read like five or six back issues of
comic books and all of that stuff but
for this one I didn't Deep dive anything
about it especially for a documentary I
want to be open to learn and something
interesting happened in me doing that um
I couldn't tell at first where this was
happening like where this was taking
place like what part of the South my own
family my great-grandfather we lost all
of our land because of aish property so
I'm thinking are we in Mississippi are
we like where are we especially she goes
I'm from Louisiana she goes oh we used
to come down from New Orleans and I'm
like oh man maybe this is I'm I might
know these people it's such a familiar
story yet the loss of land that
African-Americans particularly the
descendants of slaves here have have
gone through it's so underreported and
not talked about we don't really have
these types of conversations why do you
think that is and what did you yourself
learn about that through making the film
well I think one of the reason is that
it's it's profoundly uh
traumatic you know uh since the film uh
have started to be screened I met a lot
of people who you know in the Q&A
afterwards were saying they just realize
the same way you also realize I have the
same problem in my family and sometimes
it's one two or three generation back
but you know we all basically come from
somewhere yeah you know so uh that the
story is is not so told is because a lot
of those Community keep the story fors
you know it's not something you know
like the real family they are very
isolated in merid in cat County a family
you know resisting a whole power
structure you know the again we were
saying you know the lawyers know each
other the judges know each other the
Mayors the uh the promoters you know
it's a small crowd so um it's it's
really traumatic for the family uh uh to
to really try to go beyond and it's
usually the same case for many other
families you know that stay uh it's it's
a shame for sometimes for the family
themselves that they find themselves in
that situation you know they they feel
deprived of anything even of their
citizenship you know so um I I I want to
say the last two years I've I've seen a
lot of Articles coming out on the
subject everywhere uh in this nation you
know and many other minorities you know
and um so I do hope that uh it's coming
out now you know the same way uh people
can recognize well it's not only me it's
not only my family and and many uh uh
individual also buried that memory very
far away because it's traumatic it's
it's something like it's a sort of being
rape or sto from you know who you are
because it's your identity as well so
it's it's not easy sometimes to go back
to that and sometimes parents are just a
shame that happened to them because they
could wouldn't keep whatever their
ancestor left for them for them yeah
that pain that trauma uh the documentary
does a good job of mixing what you shot
with what they shot with other footage
that came from news sources and things
like that tell us a little bit about the
production of it um how long you were
with them what you were able to put
together there's also a lot of art that
goes into it you guys use some painting
in there some illustration it was very
creatively done and very immersive for
the audience talk a little about that
yeah well the big um ordeal was not
ordeal complication was to to make uh
out of a
incredible research uh uh object
thematic uh out of many different people
uh and many a long process of multiple
decades uh to make a film out of it and
I didn't want to make the usual
informative documentary or journalistic
documentary I always try no matter the
subject to make a real film so uh first
of all I had what I consider archive
those are the incredible hours of
material that was shot by lizy and her
team you know they spent a lot of time
with the family you can see you don't
feel the camera they just there you know
they they go about their lives they they
go about their pain and their Joy their
parties and so that material that went
over at least three three years I
considered it like the core Archive of
the project so that even before I start
shooting I work with my editor Alexandra
Strauss uh about okay what do we choose
and under what angle do we choose uh you
know what we want to
keep uh and I had make several important
decision one was that I wanted the
family to tell the story and I would not
do what usually is ask for that kind of
documentary is to show both side for me
there were not not both Sid tell me what
you mean by that what would have been
side to show you know go to the mayor go
to the uh the the company that bought
the the land and have a sort of dialogue
or contradictory
dialogue for me it's the usual story why
would have spent you know an hour and a
half of precious movie time into showing
again and again the same people who have
the power of language who have the power
of telling their own story for for
decades since Cinema exists so for me it
was giving the whole Podium to the real
family let them tell their story with
their own words with their own humor
with their own pain and and don't bother
about what other people think or what is
the real issue behind that why is this
promoter insisting after years and years
to get that piece of land
with with which he cannot do anything by
the way you know and so um that was an
artistic choice and a political choice
you know and to choose the two women to
tell the story that's so once I had that
I what I did I EXT truck about 40
minutes of archive what I call archive
that I thought okay that's the story and
then so when I went to shoot I could
exactly shoot what I
wanted to finish the movie you know like
spend more time with Mami spend more
time with uh like Curtis with the two
men spend more time with Kim and uh
which is different normally in a such a
documentary you go and try to shoot
everything the longest possible and then
you create your narration on the editing
table here that was a different process
I I uh the the inquiry Li's inquiry was
you know incredibly precise and perfect
and so I felt I was protected by that
you know I didn't have to inquire myself
about the other side what I call the
other side I could have gone and
interrogated the sheriff yeah you know
but for me it would have been another
film MH we have seen that before you
know so it was um hard to stick with it
but that's what I wanted to do and when
I shot and I could shoot in very precise
uh timeline uh I could go for 10 days
but because I knew exactly what I was
going to get you know I knew I have to
spend at least one or two days with
Melvin in the forest yeah because that's
where he lives that's that's where he
breathe Etc right uh I knew I would have
to spend more time with Le certis
because he's not very tative he doesn't
speak a lot he's uh you know it's like
it's this traumatic thing is in his head
all the time um and so I knew I have to
catch him at a moment where he will
really feel comfortable with me right
and and so I I did his interview very
late uh um maybe the day before I
stopped so yeah so it it was PR
precisely a film where uh I knew exactly
what I was I needed to tell a film and
also what you call the the the drawings
you know I I needed to give them some
sort of nobility you know and and make
them inside a narrative not a news story
you know it's it was about the life of
real people so I had to use all the
tools I know in my craft to make sure
that it's more much more than that it's
a film that you can watch another time
you know so it has to be a film right
not a report right um the film I've also
I also mentioned to you the film is
inciting it's uh it's it gets your
dander up it may I was just to be honest
with you excuse my language it pissed me
off right um and I think it get to one
point in the movie where Billy is about
to go confront the men that are
essentially ripping his family's Legacy
down and it's such a poignant part of
the movie because with where we are
right now we know what a confrontation
with law
enforcement uh can produce we've seen it
um and and I'm watching and I I hear the
voice of the black woman saying don't go
over there don't go over there and I see
him do it anyway and I'm torn in that
moment because I both don't want him to
go and I do want him to go uh being that
people will be incited by the movie and
they will be um enraged by what this
family was put through what do you want
them to do after they've seen the film
if there was a call Al to action that
came from it what would you want that to
be well there there are several thing
and and by the way I always say for for
the film I try to make it's these films
are always the beginning of something
they are not I don't make produce that
you can just consume and forget about it
it's it's if they are uh wellmade they
should uh uh push something you know
that you as individual and eventually
collectively you know uh in that case
you know look at your own family by
example ask your parents ask your
siblings you know where do we come from
what is our story and what does our
story play today what role it plays uh
and second uh of course we try to
activate organization who have been
working for decades on that very
particular subject you know we have a
website on Amazon that explain all the
thing you can do uh toward make that
those problems better uh there there
will be a a farm bill
2023 and we hope that Congress will by
example renew uh the money that was
voted to help clear titles for he family
in particular and even expand that
program because it's to it's National so
that and call your congressman make sure
that uh you know there is even more
effort to be done but it it's a it's a
uphill battle uh you know you probably
know the story of the black farmers who
where Congress did vote money for
specifically help black farmers who are
most of the time don't get the you know
after Hurricane or after any uh you know
type of of natural disaster don't easily
have access to money sometimes because
they their paperwork is not in what you
know the conditionalities are made so
that they don't really have access to it
and they basically renounce to that
money because the the the you know the
the thing that they would need to do is
absolutely uh um impossible so there are
all sort of activities and we are trying
through that website as well to give
addresses contacts and and that it
becomes a place where people can gather
and collectively uh decide for
actions so the film's narrative is both
told through what's happening to the
reals family and through the Family
itself I mean we start off with this
amazing matriarch and she's having her
95th birthday then we go back past her
and we go all the way back right uh till
1866 and by the end of it we doing a the
the and the kids is nighing and we
having fun at the family reunion so we
essentially
tell three four generations of
stories uh and not just of a family but
of a trade in terms of people who are
out on the water um what do you think
the future of the reals family
is well they have been through the worst
already so I think they they will
survive and they are organizing
themselves and and we are helping them
also get the proper help and and um um
you know
expertise uh to make sure that the rest
of the land that they have will be
secure and that they can clear all of
their titles so that's that's the good
thing about about the film but I think
more importantly for them I realized
that uh in the process that uh so we
made we did a a screening for the family
uh for the seven of them in rally we
organized a screening room for them
because I wanted them to see the film
before I I make p picture
look um that was the minimum I could do
um
and at the end we went to lunch and
mommy one thing she said she said now I
I feel lighter because I will not be the
only one to have to tell that story you
know so I understood how important for
them it was why they welcome us uh that
many times and open their doors for us
they they give us their whole intimacy
their pain and and that was their their
goal you know to make sure that they
they can break away from that little
bubble in in merman County you know and
so that's one of the thing that I think
the film brings it's for them to to feel
that they are in a bigger Collective
it's not their only little case uh but
you you touched to something about the
the how the film uh start and then
finish one of the thing that um we are
you know a lot of documentarists are
fighting right now is about you know the
the the almost obligation to to tell the
whole story the first two three minutes
of a documentary expand on that what do
you mean well because we are in a world
of of subscriber and people are always
afraid that you're going to go to the
next channel oh we're talking about
taking the and that and at the beginning
you basically have a trailer at the
beginning of your film and in that sense
for this particular film is almost as
you asked me to you need to say who
those black people are are they victim
or criminal I mean I'm caricaturing a
bit but that's bottom line what it means
and I say no this film we need to spend
time with the family first we need to
feel them as human being and not as a
case not as as you know as as criminal
or angry black man or
victims so it it was important to spend
time with them the same way I spent time
with them to understand them and to feel
like gud could be my grandmother You
Know letis M they could be my uncle I
have a lot of uncles like this you know
and and so we need we needed to spend
time with them before the drama comes
because the drama is just a moment in
their life it doesn't explain who they
are doesn't explain their story the
story is bigger than that so I had to
continue toward the end uh where
typically you would have have a happy
ending when they get off of prison so
you would have a beautiful story about
two men that unjustly went to prison for
eight years but that was not the film
the core of the film is is the whole
Saga of a family and their life will
continue you know and that's important
you know that's why the the film drag to
the the ultimate you know the party the
the you know and and the kids the Next
Generation it was important to
understand the link you know it's not
just a particular moment in their life
it's their whole life yeah one last
thing one last thing about the family
then I'll ask you uh just a grander
scheme of things you know there is a
um we talk we talked about my some of
the familiarity I have with the story
like there's a all my family is born uh
buried in the same Cemetery in Marland
Louisiana everyone just like them same
one like you can start where my father's
buried and go all the way to the back
and by the time you get to the back
you're in you're in slavery times uh and
there's this honoring of our ancestors
that uh we talk about a lot but that is
actually like uh practiced every single
day still by black families in the deep
and rural South and around other parts
of that that tradition of deep reverence
for those who came before you and
about something being bigger than what
you are or bigger than Tik Tock or
bigger than Twitter or bigger than any
of those things family and the bonds
that family means are things that are
not really explored when it deals with
black people in a lot of popular culture
television movies things like that this
is a powerful ition of that did you have
that on your mind as you were making
this this is about a black family that
stayed together loves being together and
uh is existing for one another Well it
it's even go further than that it's it's
the ultimate proof that you have been on
that land for a long time is that you
know they have three different
cemeteries you know it's like on the
space of 150 160 years so what are
trof uh you need you know the
grandmother G trud was born on that land
she's 96 today you know so um 96 give it
up for Gert you guys she's sticking
around and so it's it's important to
also have that continuity you know why
is that traumatic is also because deep
down we suspect that we come from
somewhere we suspect that land is the
sort of n DNA of this country you know
what we shouldn't forget you know there
the way this the history of this country
is told is
like sometimes a few Pilgrim came and
they were innocent and they found a land
that was
empty and uh and they made something out
of it and that right there is the
biggest lie of the whole story you know
first of all the origin inab abant they
did not say that land belongs to them
this is a European concept you know that
comes with private
property so uh so not only the land was
stolen but you brought a New Concept
that you could uh in fact own land you
know that you can land is a commodity
you can buy it you can sell it and then
you added another one you can you could
own people MH and you use those people
to work on that stolen
land and what buxs me all the time is
how come that
clear uh evidence is never
mentioned you know in the whole history
of this country you know it's like the
origin original
sin and and on the other hand you you
know project and sell an idea of P
you know and that that's James Baldwin
have written extensively course yeah you
know and and that's this incredible
contradiction you know um land is so
important even when we live in majority
in cities now a day but you see the
process with gentrification is the same
and the instrument are the same you know
taxes uh law um you know reg
reglementation uh
um Power structures they're all the same
and how to deprive people who have less
power from whatever they have in terms
of land because land means also
economical stability it means also
wealth and the capacity to give wealth
to the Next Generation and all that in
particular the black population have
been deprived of it each time there were
even laws voted you know the whole uh uh
Homestead laws you know were so uh uh
redacted that uh the conditionality
could not be fulfilled by by the former
enslaved you know and and it continued
till today so you can see uh and you
call it a capitalist structure but it's
that's exactly what it is the whole
structure and
infrastructure is built
to have the result that we have
today last question for you and it's
about you yourself I've seen your
documentaries you take on a lot of
weighty stuff are you planning to like
take a dock off are you going to do like
raex a history of ice cream or you do
one about kittens puppies rainbows or
something cuz it's a lot on you brother
with a lot of the things you you you
take on the big fights how do you keep
the energy to do it well it's I I would
say it's sample in the sense that um I
came to cinema through politics uh
Cinema was always for me a means to
fight a means to tell the the more
profound story uh the only thing I
didn't think that there was a
contradiction between telling uh reality
and entertainment I think there is a way
as any artist you know you write a book
or you paint a picture or whatever there
is a way to talk about reality and and
about your history about where you come
from uh in a way that are still uh um
you can enjoy watching or you can have
anger watching but uh the idea is to
create something that can help us
individually and
collectively uh to do better or to
repair what have been done wrong so uh
yes I tend to each one of my films um I
always consider them the last on so I
make sure that I put everything in them
you know I don't know if you saw
exterminate all the brutes yes course uh
for me uh thank
you um I thought you know not only I I
would never make a film in this
city you know but that I could have ex
eventually lost my green card so right
it was because the film touched the to
the DNA of that country what I tried to
explain a few minutes ago and and that's
a story that nobody wants to to hear
that you know the United States doesn't
come out of nowhere it's European
imperialism that came and landed here
with all the consequence so this is the
heritage of the whole Century of
European uh uh imperialism and racism as
well you know so we cannot just cut part
of the history and only keep what what
we want to keep you know so my job is to
clear that up and make it understandable
and and clear because in fact it's very
clear right well um we are on Amazon
October 13th October 13th October 13 and
theat October 13 theat uh October 20th
on Amazon Amazon so you guys when you're
watching Invincible or the boys or genv
you're on there uh click on Amazon and
you guys are now all and watch it on the
theater as well watch the the as well
it's more pleasant as well um so tell
all your friends tell everybody out
there what a spectacular documentary
this is give it up for R peek one more
time thank you movie is silver dollar O
thank you for joining us
today
[Music]
yeah